Володимир Зеленський пообіцяв українцям знайти вирішення усіх проблем.
Ми напишемо мою програму разом з тобою, ми напишемо разом з людьми, всією країною.
Потім знайдемо шляхи вирішення усіх проблем, а згодом втілимо їх в життя.
Писати програму разом з країною - це було нестандартне рішення,
яке привернуло увагу виборців.
Однак постає питання, у разі обрання Зеленського президентом -
хто втілюватиме у життя пункти програми, написаної разом з країною.
Поки близькі друзі і партнери по бізнесу активно допомагають Зеленському
у його нестандартній як для України передвиборчій кампанії.
Політик-початківець засуджує призначення кумів та армійських друзів на високі посади
і питає в українців, кого вони хочуть бачити в команді майбутнього президента.
Пропонуй, хто на твою думку повинен бути прем'єр-міністром України,
генеральним прокурором, головою СБУ, міністром закордонних справ
та міністром оборони – зробимо це разом!
У такий спосіб Зеленський позиціонує себе як несистемний кандидат.
Дописувачі, наприклад, серед інших кандидатур, пропонують замінити
виконувачку обов'язків міністра охорони здоров'я Уляну Супрун
доктором Комаровським.
У відеоблог Володимира Зеленського запрошують експертів із різних галузей.
Так поява, наприклад, деяких відомих антикорупціонерів у розмовах в штабі кандидата
створює у виборців враження, що ці люди можуть приєднатися до команди,
якщо кандидат прийде до влади.
Ми кандидату взагалі маємо показати, як працює система.
Та я ж і хочу.
Відсутність команди тих, кого гіпотетично майбутній президент Зе
може представити на ключові посади, має і позитивний, і негативний бік.
Плюс в тому, що деякі виборці можуть мріяти про свого ідеального генпрокурора чи прем'єра,
і у них немає підстав нарікати на недоброчесність тих чи інших претендентів.
Утім інші виборці через відсутність потенційних кандидатів на головні посади в країні
не довіряють актору керувати країною, адже незрозуміло,
наскільки професійним колом людей він себе оточить в разі перемоги.
Не додають довіри і такі прорахунки,
коли днями експерти у відеоблозі Зеленського
пообіцяли зарплати вчителям у 4 тисячі доларів на місяць.
Чотири тисячі доларів - зарплата вчителю у місяць.
Ми спочатку з колегою почали посміхатися, а потім порахували.
Якщо прийде весна і почнемо саджати,
то наслідку конфіскації у кількох людей буде достатньо.
Зважаючи на те, кого - може й одного достатньо.
Це сколихнуло шквал критики на адресу кандидата.
Володимир Зеленський вибачився за прорахунок.
Це викликало ще більше запитань до команди Зе.
Наприклад, екс-президент Грузії Міхеіл Саакашвілі вважає,
що команда Зеленського і стане для нього вирішальним фактором на цих виборах.
Він має сказати - ось це моя команда. Ось це мої люди.
І показати, оскільки у нього немає досвіду, ось ці люди будуть моєю командою.
Ось це буде вирішальним.
Серед пунктів програми Володимира Зеленського -
накопичувальна пенсійна система або перехід на власні енергоресурси.
І поки невідомо, як команда Зе має намір це реалізувати.